hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll if
you're interested in thinking about life
the very idea about biology right that
there exists living organisms how they
function how they go around and do their
stuff then if your cast of mind is that
of a physicist or philosopher like
myself you are struck with the
difficulty that in some loose sense
there is only one data point right of
course there is a wide variety of kinds
of living creatures here on Earth but
they all share a common ancestor all
life on Earth as far as we know stems
from a single kind of origin it's very
possible that life began multiple times
here on Earth and either one kind of
strategy one out or maybe it uh
destroyed all of the others or maybe
life only just began once but life began
and then it evolved and it's all here on
the same planet we haven't yet
discovered life elsewhere in the
universe and this is quite a handicap if
the question we're asking are what are
the general features of Life what is
life and on the level of thinking and
Consciousness and so forth what is
thinking what is the biological activity
that we think of as cognition the
subconscious you know system one system
two whatever you want to think about we
are handicapped absolutely by the fact
that we have one very big example in
front of us and not a lot of ones on
other planets or even parallel with us
here on Earth
happily if you're specifically
interested in the question of cognition
and Consciousness and sentience then we
do have more than one example now we we
only have one tree of life but as we
talk about on today's podcast the idea
of higher level thinking arose more than
once in the history of biology still
with animals that have a common ancestor
but that common ancestor did not have
higher order thinking and the other
animals we're talking about of course
are octopuses encephalopods more
generally you probably have heard if
you're interested in biology and things
like that that octopuses are pretty darn
smart even though they're not even
vertebrates right they're very very
different than
mammals or birds or insects or anything
like that so Peter Godfrey Smith today's
guest is a very respected philosopher
who thinks about Consciousness he also
thinks about other things we didn't get
to chance to talk about in the plot
podcast but he's thinking a lot about
Consciousness and takes the octopus as a
very important Touchstone for his
thinking because in some very real sense
if you go back five or six hundred
million years there was a common
ancestor to octopuses and to human
beings tiny little bugger who had no
higher conception of uh you know higher
neural system or anything like that and
over the course of evolution these two
threads diverged but they both in very
different ways developed elaborate
complicated nervous systems that do some
level of thinking it happened more than
once for different reasons right so we
can learn from about we can learn about
what it means to be a higher level
thinker what it means to be conscious
what it means to be self-aware how
cognition happens how the relationship
between the brain and the Body Works the
body of an octopus is super duper
different than the body of a human being
that's really important we need to be
able to get all the data we can in
different ways so Peter's written a
number of books but he's in the middle
of a Trilogy that we'll discuss a little
bit the first book called other Minds
which is really about octopuses in
particular and what they teach us about
thinking Etc there's another book that
came out more recently called metazoa
animal minds and the birth of
Consciousness and then he's working on a
third book about life on Earth that will
come out hopefully soon and I think it's
a wonderful conversation here I I will
point out that Peter lives in Australia
and he was in the mountains so the
internet connection came and went a
little bit but I think that we've
cleaned up the audio quality so that
it's actually pretty good at the very
end of the podcast we kind of switch
channels there and it fades a little bit
but you know the content is all there
it's all very understandable and Peter
is very very thoughtful guy thinking
about these hard philosophical questions
in a very evidence-based data-driven way
so so let's go
[Music]
Peter Godfrey Smith welcome to the
mindscape podcast
it's a pleasure to be here
so one of the things about you as a
philosopher is that your
doing field work in some sense you know
you start your uh the book that I read
other Minds with these wonderful stories
of scuba diving down there and
communicating with the octopuses and so
forth so which came first for you was it
you know philosophy LED you to dive down
there and talk to the octopuses or was
that just a separate hobby that you
realize had dramatic philosophical
implications
it's more the latter what happened was
um you know I've spent a long time
thinking about Evolution and the mind as
philosophical well philosophical
scientific topics also spent had spent
quite a bit of time thinking about the
evolution of the Mind
but I in a way that seems a bit odd in
retrospect I'd never really gotten to
know some particular animal some
particular non-human animals really well
I I hadn't sort of dived into the
biology of some particular kind of
organism it was all a bit schematic and
then it just happened by chance that I
began spending a bit more time in
Australia during the northern Summers I
was working in the U.S at that time but
was coming back a bit more and spending
time in the water and in particular just
really through a stroke of luck I I
happened to choose a spot to buy a tiny
holiday you know summer apartment in an
area that had not long before been made
into a complete Sanctuary a marine
Sanctuary where nothing can be taken
from the water
um and it's become you know a Wonderland
an amazing an amazing place I began
spending time in the water there just
because I was that's where I was
spending my Northern Summers
and the animals that made me realize I
should I should you know change my
direction a little bit changed my
thinking the first ones were the giant
cuttlefish these extraordinary you know
very large
color changing cephalopods relatives of
octopuses but closer to squid I met them
and the the color change and also the
fact that they have in some cases a kind
of inquisitive
mode of interaction with with snorkelers
and divers really intrigued me and
octopus is then with the next animals I
took it interesting you know once I
began thinking about cephalopods
octopuses are the ones that we know a
lot more about
and they had also been down there in the
water with me when I first became
interested in the giant cuttlefish they
were watching me the whole time I now
realize without me seeing through their
camouflage
so I just became very interested in the
animals
and in particular
with the feature of their lives that
forms the core of the book other Minds
which is the evolutionary relationship
the fact that they they're so distant
from us as animals now mollusks you know
oysters uh closer relatives to them than
we are but they have this complexity
this lot these large nervous systems
this inquisitive in some cases mode of
interaction and that combination of
features the complexity and The
evolutionary distance made me realize
right I I need to spend a lot of time
with these animals
and just thinking about their importance
so that that was the beginning of the
kind of combined philosophical slash
field work side of my of my life and the
big picture issue that we're talking
about here is consciousness maybe or at
least that's how philosophers often and
scientists for that matter like to frame
it but as you say maybe what you're
after here is more sentience or
self-awareness or something like that
yeah I've gotten used to the fact that
the word Consciousness has I think just
changed its meaning somewhat in the last
uh 30 years or so when I was a a student
you know thinking about the classic Mind
Body problem it was more common to think
of the word Consciousness as referring
to some kind not just experience or felt
experience in general but some kind of
sophisticated
form of experience that includes a kind
of here I am reflective kind of quality
so back then the question
is a squid conscious would not have
meant what it tends to mean now which is
just does it feel like something to be a
squid and that is what it has come to
mean largely as a consequence of Tom
nagle's uh enormously influential work
and and Nagel's work goes goes way back
it's not as if he began
expanding the meaning
uh recently he always used the word
conscious in this broad sense and there
were people who did but I have a bit of
resistance I I guess I've sort of given
up the fight to some extent I have a bit
of resistance to understanding the word
conscious in this super broad way where
it refers to essentially the same thing
as sentience
or perhaps it's the case that the word
sentience carries with it particular
implications of Pleasure and Pain
sometimes that's what people understand
by sentience
um of of become reconciled to the fact
that he's a squid conscious just means
does it feel like something to be a
squid so the faintest the faintest
glimmer of felt experience is enough for
yes answer now one one reason why I have
become relaxed about about this is the
fact that I don't think the terminology
we have now is permanent I think the
language will change I think as we learn
more in a scientific context and also in
a philosophical context the language
just naturally mutates
so I don't mind a certain amount of
slippage in the terminology
and this has a critical side to it too
when people talk about Consciousness
including in this broad sense they
sometimes suppose that you know we have
now latched on to a natural kind a real
feature of the world that we can see the
Contours of pretty clearly and that we
just have to explain with respect to how
it fits in I don't think that I think
probably the whole framework that we use
in this area will will shift will
permute will mutate in in a natural kind
of way
good because actually that's what I was
going to suggest and sort of ask whether
or not you felt the same way but to some
extent to me it seems like this
particular usage of the word
Consciousness and the focusing on what
it is like is I don't want to be too
prejudicial here but it seems like it's
meant to comport with a view that
Consciousness isn't something completely
physical right that if you focus on the
first person perspective you're almost
trying to define a way the possibility
of just having it be emergent from atoms
and particles and neurons bumping into
each other in ways that obey the laws of
physics that's not something I've
thought uh I I understand the thought
but I I that's not how it struck me
um if someone
right the word Consciousness is supposed
to steer us towards the first person
point of view
but I think that to do this need not be
to steer us away from a physical or a
biological understanding
um points of view are things that have
evolved you know Evolution has given us
animals which an animal is a kind of
Nexus between the causal lines coming in
through the senses and the causal lines
going out through action point of
viewness is an evolutionary product I
think you know Evolution built systems
that have points of view and at least so
far in what I've said they can be wholly
physical completely biologically
comprehensible systems once you have
them once you have these things through
evolution
the the things that have these points of
view will be able to
um sort of look out from those points of
view and certain puzzles will arise from
trying to marry together uh the world as
it appears from a first person point of
view from the world as described using
scientific theories that are you know
designed to not be point of view
dependent or point of view involving
so puzzles will naturally arise but I
see those puzzles as arising as a
consequence of the fact that Evolution
has built systems with points of view so
you know in a way I almost have the
opposite view I think when when people
invite us to think about the problem of
Consciousness using Notions like
subjectivity and point of view I think
okay good right fine I can I can get a
handle on that I can get a biological
purchase on that
the idea of qualia these sort of pure
fields that are also sometimes used to
express the problem
I think of those as a bit more alien a
bit more unhelpful
okay that makes perfect sense I'll I'll
buy that and you you've already kind of
led us into uh sort of the beginning of
your journey here because if I can uh
summarize it or at least you know the
set the stage if you want to study what
conscience Consciousness is sentences or
something the more data the better and
you've been emphasizing uh very vividly
in your work that there is another set
of organisms we can look at other than
we humans primates mammals Etc
right there's another set of organisms
and these organisms are all different
degrees of remove from us
when we're looking at a chimp when we
relate to a chimp it's a close cousin
the brains have a very similar structure
we share a lot of history
uh there are big differences but they're
close kin when you look at a bird a
parrot for example
the brain still has a vertebrate
structure but there's less shared
history there's it's a deeper
evolutionary relationship then you get
to an octopus and they're just miles
from us uh octopus is the same distance
from us as an ant or a bee so you know
the common ancestor between a human and
an octopus is the same animal as the
common ancestor between a bee and a
human that the lines converge there at
the same place
so you have a cluster of organisms that
are part of our our line or our group
and in a sense I mean this is now using
the word a bit a little bit
broadly they're part of the same
experiment the same evolutionary
experiment and then you have a cluster
of organisms that are just miles away
just you know really on a different Road
separated by very deep History part of a
different experiment maybe just to get
on the table for those of us who are not
complete octopusophiles uh how smart are
octopuses what does it even mean to say
that they're smart I mean we can argue
about whether or not they're conscious
and you'll have some opinions about that
but you know let's point out that
they're pretty darn Smart in some ways
I've started to
just a little bit that term I mean in a
low-key way of talking yeah they're
smart they have big nervous systems they
can do a lot of stuff they can they can
solve simple puzzles uh they're quite
good at navigation they're pretty good
Learners and so on
um the reason I've begun to resist that
word smart is is the following
there's a way of being a complex animal
that we share with for example
um well crows and parrots birds for
example which is a kind of reflective
ruminative way of being
um there are experiments on crows in
particular where you present the crow
with a novel problem it's got to solve
some problem to get food and the crow
will it'll sit there it'll just look and
little time will pass and after a while
it will do the right thing you know it
will solve the problem it's obviously
turned a problem over in its head the
complexity of its handling of the
problem is in there in the case of an
octopus I mean it's not that the the
contrast is completely Stark and
enormous but in general you know that's
that's not how an octopus would handle a
novel problem and this is partly why
experimental work on octopuses can be
frustrating they their approach to a
novel situation you know if they're not
frightened if they're going to engage at
all is to involve their body the
complexity of the body this
extraordinary body where everything
that's being touched is being tasted
they'll manipulate turn things over
um that kind of ruminative style that we
that we share with crows for example is
not present in them and sometimes when I
hear the word smartness you know how
smart is an octopus I think that we're
being asked to think of octopuses as
sharing that style whereas in fact they
have a different style now this this is
a bit of a frustrating way of answering
your question I realize
um
there are things they're not just
complex behaviorally and centrally
complex animals but they do have a kind
of adeptness they can they learn their
way around situations they can work out
what's going on in the lab they can
remember individual humans in a lab or
aquarium who've treated them nicely or
less nicely and respond to those
uh they often seem to wait until the
moment that you're not looking at them
before trying to make a break for it
before trying to make an attempt at
Escape when you're not looking that's
when they go so there's a you could see
those as a kind of
smartness as well as behavioral
complexity but I would not put them in
the same
ballpark as parrots and crows with
respect to that that reflect not
reflective that that highly cognitive
problem solving mode of complexity that
they have I hope that's not too
frustrating uh
an answer to the question we could
follow up uh
further with that if it was
you know frustrating is completely fine
as long as you're teaching us something
which is absolutely going on but I mean
maybe if we were being very very literal
about it is there a way to just quantify
the size and scope of the octopus brain
and nervous system compared to humans
for example
yeah sure an octopus or at least the
common octopus the one that's been
studied most which you get especially
around the Mediterranean uh
has at most recent measures about 500
million neurons in its nervous system so
that puts it you know well below us but
getting into the range of vertebrate
nervous systems now those 500 million
neurons are organized differently they
are with just two-thirds of them are
spread around the body especially in the
upper arms rather than being
centralized in a central brain
but even the sensual brain itself that's
that's you know that's well over 100
million neurons that's that's a big
nervous system now
here again not wanting to be difficult
one of the things that's become clear
over the last few years is how
astounding the cognitive abilities of
honeybees and Bumblebees are and they
have about a million neurons so a 500
the size of an octopus brain uh
um or nervous system so you know much
much smaller so a miniaturized brain can
do a lot as the lab of Las chitka has
shown bees can do things like cultural
learning they can see it at 1B solve the
problem and then solve the problem
itself
um there are hints of that in octopus
work from some years ago but they really
only remained hints uh whereas in the
case of the bees it's pretty solid so
bees are doing that with a brain that's
a 500th the size of an octopus nervous
system I I think one thing that tells us
is not to put too much stock in just the
numbers
that's perfectly fair and it's yet
another reminder that biology is very
complicated and physics is a superior
science to think about because things
are much easier in the realm of physics
but maybe we can go back to something
you've already mentioned because I
really want to drive this home about the
moment when our two evolutionary lines
diverged I mean the story we're telling
is what however you think about the
intelligence or whatever of an octopus
they have a quite sophisticated nervous
system and ways of dealing with the
world but that's not and so do we but
for completely independent uh
evolutionary reasons in some sense these
are two examples of complicated nervous
systems evolving very separately and
maybe talk about when that happened and
what the common ancestor was like yes
this this is a great topic I I I'm happy
to talk in a bit of detail about this
because things are changing there's uh
there's all sorts of new possibilities
arising when I wrote the book other
Minds
um I said our best guess of the time of
the depth in time of the common ancestry
is about 600 million years ago
an important uh feature of that number
is the fact that it's before the
Cambrian explosion
which began about 540 million years ago
it's it's well before that and it's
during a time that's called the
idiacaran it's named after a place in
South Australia as it happens
and during the idiacaran
you know we don't really know what
animals we're getting up to in any
detail at all but the impression we have
is it was a much quieter uh regime of
animal life than what than the regime
that began in the Cambrian in the
idiacrum we had lots of fossils they're
mostly uh they're sort of flat bottom
dwelling
creatures one of them looks a bit like a
bath mat some of them look a little bit
like sort of flattened trilobites
macaroons flattens
um forms like that and there's very
little evidence of any interaction
between one animal or another there's a
little bit that seems to have been a
little crawling creature that may have
tracked
uh others presumably in the service well
with the goal of Scavenging and or
perhaps the first forms of predation but
the sort of interaction that we
associate with animal life now where
there's lots of predation lots of
interaction that seems to be that seems
to be missing from our from our evidence
now something that's always bothered me
about reconstructions of this stage in
history are the fact that you're looking
at fossils which
um tend to be of animals that lived on
the sea floor and there's independent
genetic evidence that jellyfish or
jellyfish relatives jellyfish-like
beings were had already gotten going
around that time
what were they getting up to I mean when
I paint the picture of the sort of quiet
ediacaran a time that has occasionally
been referred to as sort of the garden
of ediacara this sort of peaceful this
peaceful early time
there is the possibility of kind of
jellyfish Warfare up in the water column
which we don't know about because those
animals don't tend to fossilize in a
recognizable way they're even less
likely to fossilize than the flattened
ones that we tend to see
anyway so we should picture that time
and the animal that's the common
ancestor of acid and octopus was
probably
a perhaps a flattened worm or a
worm-like creature on a scale of you
know again no one really knows but maybe
something like a centimeter something
like that scale with a nervous system we
know that nervous systems had evolved
already they have either one origin or
perhaps two but the origin that's
responsible for our nervous system and
the octopus nervous system occurred
within that historical group one time
they had a nervous system that may have
had eye spots
they probably had a very simple
behavioral repertoire it's you know
probably even picturing worm-like beings
it was probably a pretty a pretty simple
life now that's how I wrote about it in
other Minds
the people who I am in contact with and
who I respect who uh real experts in
this area people like Gaspar yakily he's
a neuroscientist
um
people like him are tending to suspect
that the history is not quite as deep
that the common ancestor of us and an
octopus may have lived around 565
million years ago or something like that
and there was a kind of relatively
concentrated uh cluster of evolutionary
events right you know leading towards
the Cambrian but still before the
Cambrian Because by the time you get to
the Cambrian explosion when you see
fossils the sort that Stephen J Gould
wrote about in his book Wonderful Life
and Cambrian fossils generally you're
seeing representatives of lots of
different present-day groups you're
seeing early vertebrates early
arthropods the group that now includes
insects and Crustaceans and so on early
mollusks earlier echinoderms so the the
the point at which those branches
diverged must have been before the
Cambrian because they were well
establish just as separate once the
Cambrian begins and
um there's lots of unknowns about the
details but that's the basic picture
uh so just just to add a little bit a
little bit more the the group that we
are part of and that octopus is a part
of is the group of bilaterally
symmetrical organisms animals animals
with a left and right as well as a a top
and bottom
and the common ancestor that the last
common ancestor that we share with an
octopus was probably a very early
bilaterally symmetrical organism so you
get this body plan evolving a body plan
with left and right up and down and that
left right duplicated structure seems to
have been a real advance in the area of
making possible Behavior emotion
um all of the really mobile animals that
we know about have that left right
structure so that evolved
before there was a lot of Mobility but
once the Cambrian occurred some time
after once the Cambrian explosion began
the the body plan that had become
established in a couple of different
lines
you know it was the perfect body plan to
then acquire behavioral complexity and
you get all these different lines
different evolutionary branches that
evolved in their own way
the sorts of behaviors that we associate
with with animal life and this this
combination of relationships the fact
that the branchings the Deep
evolutionary branchings were before the
Cambrian and then when the Cambrian
began
um there was a new regime of interaction
predation kill or be killed
you've got to start to track what
animals are around you or one of them is
liable to each you
complex behavior of alternate context
and it evolved in a context where there
were different uh
uh different designs that had diverged
before this point and you get all this
marvelous
diversity the arthropod body plan that
we see in insects and Crustaceans with
these hard Parts the toolkit body
uh the tremendous facility for motion
you know flight in the case of insects
there's the vertebrate design with a
more centralized nervous system and then
you've got the cephalopods this weird
case this weird group within the
mollusks with with no no or almost no
hard Parts a nervous system on a
different design and evolving complexity
of its own kind well it's a great story
because we have other examples in
evolution where like sight or something
like that there were independent
inventions of some particular capacity
uh it seems to me like a very complex
nervous system is highly resource
intensive there's there's good
evolutionary reasons not to do it but as
your environment gets very complicated
maybe it comes on the scene that there
are also good reasons to do it is it is
it okay to imagine that the evolution of
the complex nervous systems in the
cephalopods was for the same reasons as
for we vertebrates
question and
um
I think perhaps we should distinguish
closer and finer grained ways of
answering it at a course grained level I
think the answer might well be yes
complex nervous systems exist in order
to make possible complex Behavior
complex behavior is a way of responding
to challenges and opportunities posed by
your environment and lifestyle
once the Cambrian comes along
540 or so million years ago
animals start interacting with each
other
posing problems and offering
opportunities to each other
some groups you know not all lots of
groups did not evolve a lot of
Behavioral complexity but some of them
found a way forward that did involve
paying
the expense I mean you rightly emphasize
the expense of a complex nervous system
and making use of the complexities of
behavior that result
they're you know they're also finer
grain differences one interesting
difference Bears on the situation of the
octopus in particular
and this idea goes back to the first
discussion I know of this was in the
first edition of a a textbook you know
the cephalopod Behavior
textbook or survey written by Roger
Hanlon and John messenger some years ago
now in the last chapter they you know
they're fairly cautious writers handling
and messenger but in the last chapter
they do a little bit of speculation
about why octopuses came to have such
large nervous systems and the
speculation they offer is that well
there were reasons to get this body
but it's a very hard body to control
there's so many degrees of freedom you
don't have a particular location on your
arm where the elbow is anywhere can be
an elbow if you decide that that's where
your elbow is going to be and the elbow
can go through more uh directions of
motion than a a human elbow
so you've you've got to make
a lot more choices in a sense the
nervous system has to determine the
details of action in a far more
fine-grained way than it does in the
case of us where our bodies
both constrain and offer opportunities
and resources for movement so you have
this the octopus body evolved
probably through the the the the loss of
a shell of a cephalopod that was up in
the water column a little bit
squid-like or nautilus-like but uh where
in one evolutionary line they got rid of
all those hard Parts came to live on the
sea floor especially in reefs and things
like that and without any hard Parts the
the capacities you have for motion and
body changing and shape-shifting become
effect effectively sort of endless
but you have to actually control all
that stuff and handling and messenger
suggested that the octopus the large
nervous system evolved as a solution to
this problem of just getting the damn
body to you know do useful things
getting it to do uh things that make
biological sense and an idea that I find
very
attractive and I wouldn't want to over
do it I wouldn't want to make it sound
like it was a sort of uh a stroke of
magic or a an evolutionary fluke or
anything like that but an idea I find
very attractive is the idea that it was
the demands of the body that gave them
this very large nervous system and then
once they have this large nervous system
it was a relatively easy evolutionary
road to then become behaviorally complex
in ways that have a kind of smartness
and sensitivity about them they were
kind of set up to become behaviorally
complex animals as a consequence of the
demands imposed by the the sort of the
difficulties and the opportunities of
the of the octopus body and I don't want
to over emphasize the uh differences but
I don't underemphasize them either so
the octopus has a very complicated
nervous system lots of neurons but the
because of exactly the issues you just
were talking about about there's a
little bit more autonomy in those limbs
right and I guess one of the issues in
studying octopuses is how much central
control is there in the brain over the
limbs versus the limbs just doing what
they want right and this is one of the
great puzzles and open questions to what
extent is there a degree of autonomy in
in the limbs the experimental work
that's been done on this over the last
uh
while a few years especially some work
by Tamar gutnik and her collaborators
shows that the octopus can kind of pull
itself together
and direct and arm visually
in a relatively exact way when it has
reason to
um so that there is the capacity of that
centralized control
but when you watch an octopus just
hanging out if it's hanging out on the
sea floor it's doing its thing
quite often you see what looks at least
like
independent or semi-autonomous
exploration that the arms are doing uh
they'll sort of wander off and do their
own thing and it's possible that this is
controlled by the central brain
but probably I think it's thought not in
a great deal of detail but this is in
part because the the connections between
the central brain and the arms don't
look as if they are the right kind to
support you know really fine-grained
control of all the details
there's also been work on the capacities
of severed Octopus arms they can act in
reasonably coherent ways for a while on
their own sort of crawling uh forming
coherent looking motions and so on so if
I had to guess and I think we'll
eventually have a more complete picture
of this
I would offer a view in which
the octopus is happy to allow a certain
amount of autonomy in the arms in some
settings there's so much
neural processing power in there lots of
sensitivity lots of Senses uh an
exploratory mode is a natural thing that
the arms might be able to engage in
but an octopus also has to sometimes
pull itself together and do something
that's coherent and coordinated as a
whole organism so you know it'll pull
all its arms together and form itself
into a missile and Jet through the water
or something like that and I think of
this this is speculative I think it is
perhaps is a situation where top down
control is exerted on elements of the
body that will go their own way
at other times when top down control is
not being exerted it almost sounds like
an unruly family right with like some
parents trying to exert control over
their kids and sometimes the kids are
just wandering around and other times
the parents got to say hey like get in
line we have to get on the train or
whatever yeah I I I've occasionally used
analogies of of different kinds of
musical ensembles I I can see a bass
guitar in the background of your office
there
um I imagine
ensembles where you have a conductor but
the conductor is dealing with jazz
musicians who are going to go their own
way some of the time but you can bring
them you can pull them together into a
coherent thing when you have reason to
do so the family analogy also might be
offered I agree and that so now we have
the background we can start asking about
what it is like to be an octopus if
given that story you just told it
certainly sounds like if there is
anything that it is like to be an
octopus it's very different than what
it's like to be a centrally controlled
human being yeah I think trying to work
out what the sensory world of an octopus
might be like is something we can we can
make a little bit of progress on we can
take some steps down that road so if
you're an octopus you're quite a visual
animal they have good eyes which evolved
independently from ours but on a similar
design they have a camera eye
more like our eye than an insect eye
they
have enormous chemical sensitivity
they're touching they're tasting
everything they're touching with those
suckers
there appears to be some light
sensitivity in not in the skin of the
whole body itself uh probably saying too
much to say they can see with their skin
but a kind of perhaps washes of light
are experienced
through a whole body light sensitivity
not much of a role for hearing
if if any at all
so we can imagine a kind of sensory
world like that and then we have to
start adding The Oddities the fact that
the loops that exist between sensing and
acting
in us are going to be different in an
octopus because some of the actions are
likely to be semi-autonomous the arm
will just do its thing and that will
have sensory consequences that the arm
will track but the central brain will
also track and that's a difference and
related to that you have the big
puzzling
possible difference which concerns
selfhood the question once you have a a
more decentralized distributed nervous
system like the octopus has then even
though there's whole body coherent
Behavior
is the locus of experience radically
descented or just or centerless in a way
that contrasts with our own case now I
don't want to say I don't want to over
emphasize or overstate the degree to
which Human Experience is kind of
centered with a kind of CEO in charge of
the whole thing but the vertebrate
organization is probably one that gives
more makes for more Unity more
centeredness of experience than the
octopus nervous system and when trying
to imagine that feature I think our
imaginative capacities start to really
run into the sand or run into difficulty
well let me ask just some very blatant
simple-minded down-to-earth questions
about similarities between us and the
octopuses do you think that they the
octopuses feel pain for example
yeah I think that's that's become quite
likely the best octopus pain paper was
published a couple of years ago by Robin
crook uh and it's it uses a good
methodology what she shows is that
there's a number of different lines of
evidence
that point in the same direction uh
towards something like felt acute pain
in the octopus what she did was she used
a method where she would inject a little
bit of acetic acid vinegar into an arm
and that event showed up in a in a
number of different contexts
behaviorally and she was also able to
look at the physiology and see
physiological analogs of these
behavioral changes the octopus would
avoid a location where that event had
happened a location that was not avoided
otherwise or before but it would
favor locations that were associated
with the administration of a pain
killing or analgesic drug interestingly
the same sorts of drugs
seem to have a painkilling effect in
many different animals including
octopuses the animals would seek out a
location associated with the drug if
that had the injection but not otherwise
the octopus is groomed and tended the
injured spot wound tending is often seen
as quite good evidence for felt
experience of something like pain so
there's a whole bunch of different lines
of evidence she was able to bring
together
that don't decisively show that
octopuses can feel pain I mean it's not
as if we I think going to be able to
expect literal proof in a case like this
or at least not for a very long very
very long time but a contrast between
felt pain and something like a reflex
has now been replaced by a picture where
well either it's felt pain and this kind
of quite integrated centralized
multi-faceted handling of diversity of
the aversive event or it's all of those
things involving the multifaceted
handling of the University of the
aversive event without any experience at
all and it's hard to rule that out but
the contrast is no longer between
you know a mere reflex and something
pain-like it's it's now a very different
kind of contrast do you see do you see
what I I mean by that so I I think that
the the crook experiment has made it
quite likely that octopuses feel
something like pain and are they social
animals do they have social structures
in some sense not much at all this is
one of the another wonderful interesting
fact I mean people often in biology
think that sociality is one of the great
evolutionary Spurs to intelligence and
and the complex mind but octopuses are
not very are not very social
for a long while though regarded as
pretty much completely asocial you know
they have to meet to mate they've got to
do that but that was thought to be about
it
in the book other Minds I talk quite a
lot about a site a particular site that
was discovered off the coast of
Australia by a friend of mine Matt
Lawrence where you do see a lot of
octopuses uh a dozen or more hanging out
uh in pretty close quarters in pretty
close proximity a dozen or more in a few
square meters diameter and there they
have to deal with each other they have
to work out a way to get on we think and
you see a lot more interact you see a
lot more stuff going on than you do with
the with a solitary octopus so that they
they can deal with each other but we
think of this as pretty unusual it it's
not us they're not social animals in a
way that squid for example are but my
impression is that at least from humans
interacting with octopuses that
different individuals do have different
personalities in some sense
yeah personality is hard and biologists
are being quite cautious about the idea
of personality in octopuses partly
because a personality is supposed to uh
remain fixed over time you're the nice
guy today and tomorrow rather than it's
not it's not a personality difference if
you're nice today and you're not nice
tomorrow so individual differences that
have a kind of stability
are quite hard to track with animals uh
of this kind but it does look like
there's there is something like
personality differences and this is
going to be entirely unfair question or
maybe it's a fair question but the
answer is we have no way of knowing a
couple times on the podcast I've talked
with people who have stressed the mental
time travel aspect of human cognition
the idea to imagine future hypothetical
scenarios uh or to remember things from
the past and how crucial this is for
what we think of ourselves as humans
self-determining Etc is there any hope
for wondering whether an octopus can do
something like that can can have
different hypothetical scenarios in its
head that's that's part of The Cutting
Edge right now there's a research uh
Alexandra Schnell who's hoping to look
at that and who has done some of the
first work that's in this ballpark
that's in this area you may have heard
perhaps of a well-known study that she
was involved in with that she led a
couple of years ago where she showed
that cuttlefish not octopuses but
cuttlefish they're relatives
can exert a degree of self-control
they can forego an immediate
lesser reward in order to get a slightly
late well not that much you know a later
larger award it's an analog of the
marshmallow test famously applied to
humans
and they passed this they they she was
able to show self-control in a
cuttlefish which was remarkable and as
she sees it that's the beginning of a
sort of a research path
that looks at
um a handling of time that's more
sophisticated than we would have
expected in animals of this sort is
there any way of ever knowing whether an
octopus can have a theory of mind can an
octopus have ideas about what other
octopuses or other creatures no is that
is that part of the sophistication an
animal would have to be I think pretty
social in normal settings in much of its
life in order for that to have much of a
role for the animal I mean I should be
conscious one of the weird things about
octopuses is there's all sorts of things
they can do that don't have an obvious
rationale in ordinary octopus life
for example I mentioned a few minutes
ago that they can learn to recognize
individual humans
in a lab context and Associate
individual humans with nice and less
nice behaviors
there's no reason why an octopus should
be able to do anything like that even in
the case of other octopuses let alone
humans if they don't routinely have to
deal with each other in a in a situation
that involves at least tolerance if not
collaboration why should they be able to
recognize individuals it seems to be a
kind of a bonus a sort of a somewhat
surprising unexpected feature of their
complexity
and because there are things like that I
don't want to make too strong of an
inference of the form you know because
the octopus has no use for this we
shouldn't expect them to do it we
already have cases where it's very hard
to see why the octopus has any use for
something and they and they can do it
okay so with all that on board then uh
what have we learned I mean what what
are the lessons for how we think about
Consciousness or sentience that we get
from having arguably two data points I
mean maybe sorry maybe I should have
just asked are octopuses sentient and in
what sense
I think I think the answer is yes and I
think the the list of animals that are
probably or likely sentient
is
is a growing list and it's probably
quite a long list now
um I used to be a little wary about the
idea of insect felt experience or
Consciousness but much less so now
mostly as a consequence of the B work
now B's are special insects one
shouldn't think that everything true of
a bee is going to be true of all the
other insects but it's kind of a it's a
bit of a game changer to have to have
decent evidence uh for experience in
bees in the case of bumblebees there's a
good experiment from last year
suggesting something like pain in
bumblebees using a similar methodology
that had already been taken to be pretty
good in the case of crustaceans their
arthropod relatives where this involve
an experiment that asks will will the
animal make trade-offs will it handle
build a relationship between
apparently aversive events and rewards
in a sophisticated way
a way that suggests that the aversive
event is felt to be aversive in the case
of bees
I think we have pretty good evidence
that they do feel aversive events if
they feel them but they're feeling
something and they have remarkable
sensory abilities lots of insects have
remarkable sensory abilities
we have them we have the octopuses we
have the pain experiment I talked about
a little while ago
something else I emphasize is the fact
that
if you get a Consciousness researcher on
from psychology or Neuroscience someone
like Stan dehane if you you know put
such a person on the spot and say what
what are the behavioral
indicators not proofs but indicators of
Consciousness what's something that we
can see from the outside that's at least
very strongly suggestive of the right
kind of Machinery to be conscious
one thing that at least some of those
people might say to you and I mentioned
Stan dehane as an example is we're
dealing with novelty producing novel and
temporally organized behaviors behaviors
that are far from routine because in
humans even if you think that humans can
do a lot of things unconsciously
the evidence that we can do a lot of
things unconsciously stops when you get
to novel
temporally organized behaviors and see
sequential behaviors that are new
then people are conscious of what
they're doing
and octopuses are full of behaviors like
that you know they they like novelty
their response to novel objects is very
much non-routine they're curious about
objects that they'll do you know an
octopus today can do something that no
octopus has ever done before uh because
of their inclination towards novelty so
we have the pain work we've got this
this this orientation towards novel
behaviors
uh we've got the large nervous system
we've got the uh we've got I think lots
of lots of indicators of of felt
experience or Consciousness in this
broad sense in octopuses
so that's interesting because
as you've already told us the octopus
nervous system is wildly different than
ours there's some similarities but a lot
of differences so can we draw
conclusions then about what are the
features of a nervous system or of a
brain that would then lead to what we
think of as sentients yeah let's
let a there's a there's a few ideas I'd
like to put on it on the table in this
area some of them fairly speculative and
there's something I'd like to ask you
about it actually as well
stepping back a moment
one question we might ask is well do you
need a brain at all is there anything
special about the biological Hardware
that a brain comprises or could the
complexity of operation that a brain
enables also be seen in a totally
different sort of device so you know is
our brains necessary at all
philosophers have tended to think for
quite a long time that brains are not in
principle required for Consciousness
even if you're a physicalist because the
right kind of structure could exist in a
properly programmed computer an
artificial system could be a kind of
functional isomorph of a brain and it
would be perfectly fine as a basis for
consciousness
I don't believe those views uh this is
partly because I don't believe the
arguments for them anymore and we could
talk about that but one thing I wanted
to
perhaps spend a bit of time on if we can
is an alternative picture of what
matters and a picture in which some of
the particularities of brains you know
are quite important
so here's here's one picture of what
brains do and and then I'll describe
another picture which is the one I'm
interested in one picture of what brains
do is well it's essentially a network
the old the old analogy uh between a
brain and a telephone exchange wasn't
too far off it's been replaced by an
analogy between a brain and a network
where you have nodes connected to other
nodes and excitatory and inhibitory
links between them neurons fire and make
other neurons fire but the firing of a
neurone is just an event that uh
defines activity in a network and you
could have other sorts of physically
different networks with similar patterns
of interaction
that's a view of the brain in which the
discrete cell to cell or point-to-point
connections are all that really matters
and the rest of what's going on is just
kind of life support for the for the
network
here's another picture
um of brain activity you do have those
point to point
sell to sell influences and they're
tremendously important to the
computational side of what a brain does
but you also have large-scale Dynamic
patterns which are not straightforwardly
reducible to those Network properties
the simple example or the the most
conspicuous example is the sorts of
patterns that you see in an EEG
reading where there are oscillatory
rhythms
in a brain which do have a relation to
the neurons firing but probably also
have a lot of uh connection to sub
thresholds movements of ions over
membranes which create large-scale
electrical events which can be detected
you know from the skin with an EEG
device
and which well then the question is what
do these things do if anything a lot of
people have thought that the sorts of
oscillatory patterns that we pick up
with an energy are just kind of Epi
phenomena or froth on the surface they
don't really matter but there is a
tradition in Neuroscience of saying that
there's an important cognitive role
played by these large-scale rhythms and
oscillatory Dynamics there was a
particular moment uh which changed my
thinking about this
um
when I first it's like you know two of
the people who've who early on argued
that large-scale Dynamics especially
gamma oscillations around the sort of 40
Hertz
rate of oscillations in a brain
two of the people who argue that
oscillations of that kind might be
important to Consciousness were Francis
Crick and Christoph but uh some
decades ago
and wolf singer and some other people
argued that The Binding Together of
perceived parts of an experienced
situation might be facilitated by these
large-scale brain level you know not
just neuron to neuron oscillatory
patterns
and I always when I when I heard about
that I thought well that's that is very
interesting but this just sounds like a
kind of Quirk of some brains or
vertebrate brains it might just be true
of us
and then I met a guy Bruno van swinderen
who's a fly researcher here in Australia
who studies exactly the same kind of
thing the role between large-scale
oscillations in the brain brain rhythms
essentially and cognitive processes but
he studies it in flies and it turns out
that flies show an association between
selective attention attending to a
particular part of the scene and
particular large-scale brain rhythms
there's an apparent cognitive role for
these oscillations which are which are
not straightforwardly reducible to the
point-to-point neuron fires then other
neurons fire properties there's an
association between those properties and
and experientially relevant cognitive
role in flies and when I learned that I
thought right my whole view of what a
nervous system is is suddenly is being
changed here I shouldn't just think of
them as these big networks with one cell
affecting another cell I should think of
a nervous system as a different kind of
thing where you have a combination of
those point-to-point interactions and
these more diffuse more integrated
holy biological when I say they're not
straightforwardly reducible to the
network properties I don't mean they're
not reducible to the biological
properties they they involve the
movement of ions across membranes within
the brain
but they're not they're not networkish
in the way that I'd been told by
everybody
I've been told everybody that the
network is properties are all that
matters and the rest is just life
support
and it turns out that these oscillatory
dynamics that are again not reducible to
the network properties they're all over
the animal kingdom they're there in
flies they're they're in octopuses
they're even there in animals with much
simpler nervous systems
uh jellyfish-like animals including
jellyfish
so it's it's a feature of nervous
systems that they have this Duality
between the network properties and the
uh more diffuse electrical Rhythm type
properties
and I think it's possible to start
to suggest some mappings between that
combination of features in nervous
systems and experience as a phenomenon
felt experience
should I dive on into that or should we
talk a bit about I'm curious what you
think about
the uh the general electrical profile
that brains have the role of field
effects things like that
yeah yeah let me just say a little bit
about that and then I would love to hear
you know you you continue on about uh
experience and and it and its connection
here
I am very much one who argues against
things like strong emergence or downward
causation or and things like that when
the lower level of description that
we're talking about is truly microscopic
physics right atoms or particles or
fields we know in the physics of
individual Elementary particles that
their Dynamics are entirely local what
an electron does only depends on what
its immediate environment is it does not
depend on whether or not its broader
environment is a rock or a brain or an
Interstellar gas cloud or whatever but I
I do think that that fact may be
obscures the fact that when you're
talking about the relationships between
two levels both of which are kind of
complex themselves right like the
relationship between neurons and the
Brain neurons are not Elementary
particles they're not entirely local I'm
very much open into them being
influenced by not just the neurons that
they're talking to in the network but
wider scale phenomena certainly if we
talk about
societies where the lower level is
people and the upper level is countries
or or communities or whatever of course
people are highly non-local things they
are affected not only by the other
people they talk to nearby but by things
going on in the in the wider world so I
would guess not being an expert on the
brain at all but I would guess that
maybe this is this could be an example
where our enthusiasm for a certain kind
of reductionism takes us too far
thinking about neurons and their
connections with each other and ignoring
uh more holistic aspects which are
perfectly compatible with physicalism
but maybe a little subtle from the point
of view of what individual neurons do
does that make any sense
yes and you use the word there with that
you are avoiding and that I would also
avoid the word emergence I I don't I
don't like emergence as a
theoretical tool in this area I think it
causes more trouble uh it causes trouble
more than it's it solves problems
so I wouldn't describe the sorts of
things I'm talking about here in terms
of emergence
it's it's only in the if you have in
mind that sort of holy network-based
view of a brain then it's surprising to
be told that there are these more
diffuse and holistic electrical
phenomena which can make a difference
let me offer a little bit more of the
view of brain activity that van swinder
and the guy who has influenced me in you
know well it's inspired at least some
speculations
uh say a bit more about what he thinks
he thinks that there are two important
processes in brains going on at once one
is neurons making other neurons fire
the ordinary point-to-point cell to cell
interactions through synapses where this
neurone fires and it contributes to or
inhibits another neuron firing
the other process is these electrical
movements the movements of ions across
membranes in particular which are below
the level at which action potentials
will be triggered their sub threshold in
that sense
but they affect the temporal properties
of everything else that happens and they
affect the temporal properties of
firings so the sub threshold movements
of ions affect the firings of neurons
the firings of neurons affect the sub
threshold movements of ions the sub
threshold movements are more diffuse
it's not sort of you know there are
particular cells involved but as
evidenced by the fact that you can pick
up the large scale pattern with an EEG
it it has a more holistic character in a
in a low-key non-threatening sense of
the it's more of a whole brain or large
parts of the brain activity
okay suppose you think a brain is like
that suppose you think it has this
almost miraculous combination of
properties the point-to-point more
computational interactions
and the more diffuse electrical
oscillatory interactions
here's something that was noticed by a
few people who've written in this area
from different angles over many decades
in fact they've noticed that if you have
a system with that combination of
properties then it's going to be
affected by sensory events you know
incoming influences will make a
difference
but many different events will
simultaneously affect the uh the state
of the whole and the the actions going
on in the whole there's a kind of
integration for free that you get when
you have a system with this combination
of properties
one of the first guys to study uh
electrical oscillations
rhythms in a jellyfish-like animal
mention this a guy called Mac pasano
just mention this in passing Way Way
Back decades ago and the thought has
been I think independently picked up by
a number of different people in both
neuroscience and around Neuroscience the
idea of a natural integrative role that
you get from this this combination of
properties as characteristic of brain
activity
okay what is experience like what is it
like to have an experience uh any any
everyday experience like the experiences
we're having right now well something I
think is Central and that is
occasionally
um underplayed or outright denied is the
kind of gestalt-like
character of experience I'm seeing the
screen I'm hearing some stuff uh there's
a certain subtle effect in my total
experiential profile played by what the
chair is like the ambient temperature
all my mood the fact that I have had
coffee within the last hour or so rather
than not and and so on there's a there's
a sort of natural
fitting together of facets that ordinary
experience has
and one thing we want a biological
account of experience felt experience to
do is explain that property and I think
that the view of brain activity that I
was describing a moment ago
as the the newer or the unorthodox view
it lends itself very much to an
explanation of that gestalt-like view of
experience
suppose I think it's that sort of
combination of properties in us in our
brains that makes experience a feature
of Our Lives
I then look through the animal kingdom I
see all these different kinds of nervous
systems
but they all have this combination this
this peculiar combination of properties
is characteristic of animal nervous
systems in general
and I want to know as we all do which of
these organisms has
uh feelings or sentience or
Consciousness in a broad sense
that I find myself saying well I can
imagine a two-part
a two-part story about the biology of
experience the first part involves
something we talked about earlier in
this conversation which is the evolution
of point of view
perspective the fact that some systems
animals as a consequence of the
evolution of action have been formed to
have a perspective on the world a point
of view on the world with the senses
coming in actions being emitted there's
a kind of Nexus that we are as animals
as a consequence of the evolution of
behavior
that set of properties is one part of
the explanation of the biology of
experience and the other part is the
peculiarities of nervous systems the way
that nervous systems have a unique
combination of properties that features
these gestalt-like patterns of activity
being perturbed simultaneously by
various different events
so from there I think right to to be
conscious is to be an animal with a
nervous system that has
subjectivity as a feature of its
relationship to uh its environment it
has a perspective it has a point of view
it deals with the world and acts upon
the world as a subject
and there's not going to be a cut off
such that some animals are below the
line with respect to the important
properties and others are going to be
above the line and have the lights on
a gradualist picture is almost
inevitable once you have this General
Outlook there's going to be all sorts of
gradations and Shades of Gray and one
overall picture I would offer using all
this is a picture in which a whole bunch
of animals really are sentient really
are conscious lots of vertebrates
octopuses some arthropods the
Crustaceans the honeybees the bumblebees
and so on and you have a kind of shading
off very gradual
diminution and dimming and
transformation
that takes you into neurally less
complex animals
but there's not some point at which the
lights just switch off there's a hard to
understand gray area you know I wonder
whether animals like earthworms and
Starfish much more neurally simple than
us or an octopus are are in an area like
that
so gradualism
the importance of nervous systems as
unique physical objects and the
evolution of subjectivity those are the
sort of those are my those are the parts
of my view yeah I think I've it all
sounds very very interesting and
plausible to me the gradualism aspect in
particular you know is almost inevitable
if you believe in uh Evolution and so
forth although I do I do at least want
to keep open the possibility that yeah
there are in physics phase transitions
right there's underlying things that
happen very gradually which lead to
dramatic sudden shifts in the
macroscopic properties of things uh so I
think you can be both gradualist about
the foundations and suddenness
uh catastrophist about some of the
manifestations of that and I don't know
and you know in in principle some things
change slowly and some things change
rapidly I do think in human beings
there was we're in the midst of a rapid
change on biological time scales uh
stemming from our first acquisition of
language and symbolic
um ways of communicating with each other
which I I don't think other animals have
at all so I think there is some
difference even though the the DNA
difference between humans and other
primates is Tiny the the manifestations
are large and I I don't know I'm just
very open-minded and I don't know the
empirical information about whether or
not there's some similar thing about
sentience or Consciousness that might
you know be an open question about
whether or not an octopus has crossed
this barrier to the point where I can
hurt its Feelings by treating it badly
yeah
I agree very much with what with one
particular thought there this reminds me
of a conversation I had I gave an online
tour a couple of years ago
and
I said the thing
that you and I both agree with which is
in an evolutionary setting gradually
gradual change is likely we have to get
used to the possibility of gray areas
and gradations and no sharp boundaries
and I also said the thing that I've said
in this conversation about the
importance of large-scale oscillatory
Dynamics in nervous systems
and a woman whose name I didn't write
down I I've come to think of this as a
really important point I need to track
her down so I can give her proper credit
for this in the question time said well
there could be a tension between the two
things you just said basically if you
think that those
um those oscillatory Dynamics in nervous
systems are really important they are
natural candidates for phase transitions
they're the sorts of things that can
just sort of come into being when things
are just right with relatively a small
underlying substrate changes and that
would potentially be at odds with the
sort of ultra gradualist View
that you're telling us
and especially after the event was over
I thought to myself that really was a
very good point that was a good
observation I agree with that
one reason I do emphasize
the the gradualist
picture here
is the fact that if you look across
animals now there's such a diversity of
nervous system sizes and complexities
and different sorts of Lifestyles and
the idea of a Sharp line between the
ones who are in and the ones who are out
just seems very artificial to me
there was a conference at NYU a few
years ago which I remember very vividly
animal mines conference organized by the
philosophers at NYU and I gave a talk at
that one and said some things about
gradual change
and gray areas no light switch no sudden
moment where the lights come on and I
was surprised that quite a lot of people
in the audience quite a lot of
philosophers uh very prominent
philosophies in some cases they just
wanted to resist they wanted to resist
that gradualist view because they
thought we can just see from the nature
of Consciousness that it's a yes or no
matter
uh it just has to be a a yes or no
matter if we use the the Tom Nagel
formulation is there something it's like
to be you they said look the distinction
between something and nothing is a sharp
distinction it's not a it's not a graded
gray area distinction there's either
something it's like to you to be you or
there's nothing it's like to be you
there can't be something that's a bit
like there being something it's like to
be you it's it's a yes or no matter
and this also takes us back to a very
early stage in our conversation my
response to that was to think when you
say that you think we already understand
the kind of Contours of the problem very
fully we can see
from uh what we know and have explored
and it can experience now that there
there has to be a yes or no distinction
such that animals are either in or
they're out
I don't think we can I don't think we
know enough
to just to think we can see that I think
our knowledge is far too rudimentary and
the is it something is there something
it's like to be you language that
terminology it's quite a helpful way of
gesturing towards the problem but it
doesn't constrain Solutions such that
there has to be a sharp divide
so I accept very much the idea that once
I start to talk about physical
properties where phase transitions are
real possibilities
though I have to be open to suddenness
as you said
I also think there are reasons to favor
a gradualist you would you look at the
animal kingdom deadly that makes a lot
of sense to me and I will I will
um just to clarify one thing you know
there can be there may or may not be
phase transitions if there's underlying
gradualism it's open to the possibility
there are sudden changes in the
macroscopic behavior but but maybe not
and that's an empirical question we have
to look at the other thing that I'll
just throw out there is that I tend to
think that Consciousness the question
what is consciousness has some analogs
to the question what is life as in you
know biological life because in the
sense that there's probably not a unique
thing that it is right there's a bundle
of aspects that it is and not only can
some of them be sudden changes in some
of them gradual but some of them can be
existent in a certain organism and
others not so the idea that it's a just
a yes or no switch seems kind of
implausible to me I completely agree I
think life in Modern Biology has been
partly expanded and partly dissolved
it's been dissolved in the sense that
there's not some single property such
that you know here is my theory of Life
instead we understand a cluster of
properties that are broadly metabolic
that involve energy use and
self-maintenance
and as a cluster of properties that
involve Evolution and reproduction and
we understand those as well
and grams stand life there are some
organisms that have one cluster without
the other viruses have the the
production Evolution related properties
without having their own metabolism
and that makes total sense if viruses
didn't exist it would if we hadn't
discovered viruses it would make sense
to predict their existence because you
can see how it would make sense for them
to fit in and to be sort of odd cases
with respect to the Paradigm cases of
Life uh if if we look at Madden origin
of Life scenarios many of which involve
deep sea vents
and the gradual formation of chemical
Cycles in situations where the
containment
that prevents everything just diffusing
away is initially inorganic it's the
environment that's helping things remain
uh relatively or partly
compartmentalized and when the uh surf
maintaining surf reproducing systems
began to produce their own boundaries
and hence their own compartmentalization
there are models like that that have an
intensely gradualist flavor to them and
at what point in a system like that do
you go from just having a chemical an
auto catalytic cycle that's keeping its
breath going but doing so in favorable
physical circumstances at what point
where you go from merely that to being a
rule of serum that has its own firm of
life well the answer is you know don't
look for a line don't look for a divide
it's it's misunderstanding
the picture to think that there'll be a
sharp line so I think the analogy with
life is a very rich one and quite
helpful in this setting good so we've
we've gone on for a while I want to just
put one more final idea on the table
that you can respond to because it's one
that resonated with me a lot when I was
reading your book which is the
externalism idea the the importance for
consciousness of how we relate to the
outside world and the reason why it
struck me is because I've just done a
couple of podcasts where that same kind
of move appeared in very different
circumstances one with Brian Lowry who
is a social psychologist who says that
our notion of the self is fundamentally
a social one one that we use to pick out
our role in society and another one with
Hugo Mercier who claims that the reason
that we have reasons for our actions is
fundamentally a social one not we don't
just do something we say here's why I
did it that's ultimately social so in
both cases there are things that you
might think of as very very internal and
these folks are claiming that the
reasons why we we have that internal
feature is actually because of our
relationship to the external world is it
plausible that Consciousness is another
thing that has that property
is anywhere near right in Consciousness
itself doesn't have that property
but lots of things I think probably do
have that property uh I think that the
internalization of external cognitive
tools easy
a a big thing in human evolution I mean
language is the language is the
outstanding case there's a discussion in
the book other minds of inner speech
and the ideas of vygotsky the Soviet era
psychologist who made much of the the
power of inner speech as a internal
cognitive tool I think that's a very
important set of ideas you know in a
speech and linguistic organization of
thought more generally
is a kind of gift from the public to the
private it's something that makes our
individual Minds more powerful than they
would otherwise be but it's something
that would never have existed if there
wasn't a social setting in which the
tool for interaction developed
I've just finished the third book in the
series that began with other minds and
it's going to be a longer discussion of
these drifts from public to private in
that one so I think that you know the
octopus reminds us that you can be a
solitary or pretty solitary animal
with a somewhere messed up self you know
a a rather unclear form of selfhood
given that that neural dispersed
dispersal and there to be very good
evidence that you that you are conscious
in a broad sense of conscious the
octopus reminds us of that it's one of
it's one of the lessons of the octopus
but it's also true that social life
rebuilds reshapes
our internal Landscapes where you know
language again is is is the outstanding
case and there are probably others as
well
and these uh these are important in the
explanation of human consciousness even
if they're not important in the
explanation of of Consciousness as a as
a general phenomenon you got to tell us
what the title of your upcoming book is
living on Earth
living on Earth all right well we very
much look forward to it uh is that Earth
including the oceans I hope yes although
it is the most terrestrial of the books
other mines was was mostly Marine the
second book metazoa we worked up onto
land at a certain point in the book and
the third book living on Earth is a lot
of it is set in forests it's a forest
book to a large extent but with quite a
quite a a regular tendency to go back
into the water from time to time as well
so there are no octopuses there are more
marine animals but there's also a kind
of Arborio Forest based uh Vibe it's not
very complicated I admire you folks who
can really uh try to take this all in so
Peter Godfrey Smith thanks very much for
being on the mindscape podcast it's been
a pleasure thank you
[Music]
thank you